ever since the looper channel went alive
in January 2016 there is one video fans
have been requesting over and over the
untold truth of looper
well that moment has finally come
because we're here to peel back the veil
of secrecy and give you an inside look
at just what went into creating looper
so here it is at long last the untold
truth of looper die hard try hard in
this time-travel action film with Joseph
gordon-levitt and Bruce Willis play
young and older versions of the same
character an assassin named Joe who's
ordered to kill his future self Star
Joseph Gordon Levitt faced a tall task
when it came to playing the younger
version of Bruce Willis starting with
the fact that they look absolutely
nothing alike in fact the film's makeup
artists actually thought it was an
impossible task and almost quit the film
entirely director Rian Johnson convinced
them to stay and after months of
experimenting they finally came up with
a mix of prosthetics and makeup that
worked and also took three hours a day
to apply that's only one of the lamps
gordon-levitt went through in order to
deliver an authentic performance though
he religiously studied with us his
performances but he was careful to only
study newer with his films rather than
classics like die hard because he wanted
to make sure he wasn't playing a young
Willis but rather a younger version of
the older Willis G's even the behind the
scenes preparation for the story is too
confusing to understand the four-page
script when the film hits theaters in
2012 Johnson actually came up with the
idea for looper ten years earlier back
in 2002 at first it was supposed to be a
short film and Johnson worked out his
initial idea in a little four-page Draft
which didn't include most of the
twistier thriller aspects of the
finished film but the hearts of Joe's
story is all there something curious
fans can see for themselves as the story
is posted online Thank You Christopher
Nolan director Christopher Nolan's
twisty dream thriller Inception opened
two years before looper and became a
major critical and commercial hit
according to Johnson Inception was a
revelation for him he saw it as proof
that a wide audience would accept a
complex sci-fi movie if it's made well
inspired Johnson dubbed that short story
out of the drawer it had been
languishing in for years and
for the full scripts for looper
eventually signing on his old friend and
inception actor gordon-levitt to
headline the project that's what we call
closing the loop low-five Syfy there's a
ton of cool science fiction stuff in
looper like flying bikes but there was
almost a lot more Johnson revealed that
he often had to ask the special effects
team to tone down their designs because
he wanted the future to look as
realistic and plausible as possible
he told Time magazine as a sci-fi geek
it took a lot of discipline to say well
that looks really cool but let's pull
that way back the diner was too
authentic one of the most memorable
scenes in looper involves are not so
firmly meal at an old-timey diner it's
here that old Joe and a young Joe
finally get a little face time allowing
gordon-levitt to learn a thing or two
about table manners the donor is cool
but even cooler is the fact that the
whole thing was built from the ground up
on location in Louisiana just for those
scenes but the finished set was so
authentic locals kept interrupting the
construction to ask when the diner would
open sadly you're need time trouble
yourself to visit it because the fake
diner was reportedly torn down in 2014
no family values if you watch the
trailer and thought looper was a tense
sci-fi thriller you were only half right
the heart of the story involves a little
boy who may or may not grow up to be a
terrible villain in the future but you
wouldn't know that from the marketing
campaign which didn't mention the family
drama at all Johnson said Sony shied
away from those aspects because it's a
bit harder to sell those elements on a
poster or 2-minute trailer a trailer
that didn't actually give away the
entire story the future might be worth
living in after all from Paris with love
everybody wants to travel the world even
futuristic hitmen and Joe eventually
winds up in China that's was a
last-minute change though the script
actually called for Joe to end up in
Paris but after crunching the numbers
Johnson realized it didn't have the
budget to film in France that's when the
film's Chinese distributor dmg offered
to foot the bill if they filmed those
scenes in China instead Johnson agreed
and the rest is well history loopholes
having someone close our own loop is a
critical part of the film's world
building but
not something Johnson explicitly
explained in the film itself it wasn't a
plot hole though in fact early drafts of
the script included a whole scene where
Abe played by Jeff Daniels explained
that people in the future are
desperately trying to protect a time
line from being messed up by you know
immoral thugs wielding guns Johnson
explains the backstory as to why the
assassins have to close their own loops
people in the future all they know about
time travel is to be afraid of it so
they're trying to keep as tight as
possible so the initial reason they set
it up this way with the keep the
causality loop as tight as possible
every bit of evidence has gone from not
to loop when you kill yourself but as
good as that explanation is it's not
hard to prefer old Joe's disinterest in
talking about time travel and want to
talk about time travel because if we
start talking about it don't going to be
here all day talking about and making
diagrams with straws good cool look at
all these things no one's got time for
all that nonsense not even the doctor
wants to get into all those dirty
details people assume that time is a
strict progression of cause to effect
but actually from a nonlinear
non-subjective viewpoint it's more like
a big ball of wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey
stuff thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]